[Music]
my fellow bros my fellow brethren my
fellow comrades the time thank no more
will we become stressed by mainstream
media no more will I take this online
abuse and hatred no longer will I say
I'm sorry I messed up okay and you know
why because we're failing another
YouTube channel is changing over them
he's taking over that's right
ain't no less than in November this year
PT pi will not be the biggest channel on
YouTube no we must fight back who is
this t-series channel this channel will
pass Beauty baby number one I'm number
one
no more lame boxing matches I challenge
t-series into a saber fight like real
man I'm throwing my goal about UT Series
fight me IRL
to the death no boxing glove and helmets
I'm talking about to the death here wait
they have 46 billion views it's an
Indian Channel it's an Indian Channel
it's an Indian Channel India I will
fight you all and your name you're
watching this channel you're welcome
how many people live in India
possible too many the only way I can
stay relevant is to get the Indians
subscribing to me if they want to accept
my sword challenge than the only thing
we can do is fight fire with fire man
subscribe smash so play smash sub sprite
nice subscribe smash subscribe what are
we gonna do that's right I just want you
to review the memes I don't really feel
it yeah I've seen this already yeah it's
so good it took me a second the first
time I saw it and I'm like what do you
mean I didn't see this video like what's
the context here and why their editing
skills has approved or post my loans
Andrus damn that's savage when you have
memes ready for ksi loosing to Logan
Pole and also means ready to Logan fall
losing 2k site and it's a draw
excuse me a scout I had the same thing I
had two thumbnails prepared and it was
really annoying I had to make one last
minute what the heck guys couldn't you
have picked a winner you were gonna have
a rematch anyway why make it a draw you
clearly already planned for it it would
have been more exciting for someone to
win to them guessed its title back
instead of a draw
no one cares fortnight did it that's
right everybody
Aloha Epic Games did this like genuinely
it's a great meme well done
I don't know why I'm like holding this
standard that I hate for a night for
some reason when it's clearly the
greatest game of all time at this point
me and review is not the wine main
review is not you laugh you lose all
right this is all correct your life you
lose it's not the why I mean it's all me
what do you want from me I did nothing
wrong
hey look at these cringy as reddit posts
this is great this is legendary this is
above average this is epic this is so
sad oh look we're all a part of the same
group
Wow look at this we're posting the same
joke all right original by the way let's
all make the same joke in this chain
hilarious that's why we bond damn it
we're all garbage here we roll the
bottom of the bottom flying kitty litter
and edit and it's amazing told you Kaiba
was gonna kill a PC I will YouTube's
worst show everybody meme ravine welcome
to Kupa now I don't endorse that name
[Music]
okay I am sorry if you haven't
subscribed of blankety yet I suggest you
do incredible edits a modern take on
acts on an old classic Alexa play just
procedures Alexa uses reverse uno Kurt
damn it congratulations I played myself
damn you Alexa I hate you who did it
better this is how I smile I don't
understand it what the prize I'm really
happy to do make youtube videos guys
it's a really fun job market last upload
four days ago pretty PI's lives off the
load four days ago they are marrying
some no now we weren't we went to
Budapest I uploaded a vlog you dum-dums
you dumb balls your bag of balls don't
know at once sorry that was too far I'm
so sorry wait why is there no D in me
I'll be a
who's reading these comments you know I
understand people posting it but who's
reading them who goes through the
comments so this is pretty boring I
guess I'll scroll down as he puts yeah I
guess I'll check out the comments and
maybe I'll can engage in some discussion
over here what is wrong with you
I want Felix to explain why Brad
sometimes licks the video and I also
want to know which version is the real
one and the mirrored one in today's
society does it really matter what isn't
real and what is it what are you even
matters anymore
in general Who am I talks about the
guitar that's been unused for a month
takes out a different guitar oh my god
that's right epic troll got you guys
yeah subscribe we need to destroy
t-series I love you guys so much I
actually loved my audience don't say
anything
let's just get Felix to see this post
twenty eight thousand blanks don't say
anything let's just get it for you
suppose not ribbit illusion 100 scenes
today's society does it really matter
what the replica is point proven
I don't rate things that's not what I do
excuse me excuse I like a good Mars ma
the face is that Allen Walker where am i
stuck up yet what legend absolute mad
lad now Allen Walker can give all these
audience and subscribers to me we can
beat t-series that's right we gotta
merge the Great War has started which
side of history will you be on can pues
good job yeah that's how you know your
audience is virgin I know rose finally
rue you for tonight as a meme sir LLL
die ah I've already done okay it can't
be done
alright 49 is indestructible there's no
point to warm my feet to warm my hands
to warm my heart this is so sweet
Alexa don't play anything I play a
second amusing they will Congress right
this video that's what I thought yeah
speaking of which
thank you so much so neat for the coffee
strike really really appreciate it it
means nothing to me okay
don't care whatsoever go ahead he made a
cover of dismiss Ito we must shut this
down now
Farrah Williams isn't making enough
money we need to take the revenue from
Buddha pad I'm impressed
you achieved level two in heavenly I'll
be quiet person know me what Detroit
become human I like that Detroit become
human out of all games became the mean
there's always some game that's way too
popular for its own good but I always
have some meme going on wait wait wait
wait
oh okay all right
[Music]
No okay
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god gee
now stop stop stop
[Music]
[Laughter]
are you kidding me
[Music]
oh my I'm physically disturbed an
aroused at the same time this is the
power of the nine year old army right
here this is library so this was made by
auntie busser a fellow nine year old
absolute man like this is made in
February and I didn't see it
see this is why I love the reddit you
guys bring attention to me all this cool
stuff all these epic things I can
finally watch it you know when you
realize that next year PewDiePie's
channel itself will be nine year old oh
my god that's true I wonder what's gonna
happen when he turns 10 this is so true
this is so true Alexa here its first
fight with a medium Pierce now today
laugh or crying I don't know pictures of
some reptiles with weird eyes
what are you been playing that just
because I'm leeching off memes and other
people's content as a desperate attempt
to stay relevant I'm somehow a reptile
that's ridiculous
weird a reptile smile with such a human
loving smile subscribe so we can take
over TV I'm vegan now there Salman is
delicious excuse me I love this as soon
as you proclaim that you're some sort of
diet everyone just loves to be the
police as a nine year old I've been
taught to close my mouth while chewing
food this pic of him really triggers me
and why that you fellow nine year old
have such amazing etiquette I'm so
thankful that I have such an amazing
audience that draws me in such amazing
well you know I am speechless
fantastic thank you so much Mary Coe
I've been watching period since sixth
grade and my dad made his him firm II
wouldn't call you son your dad has been
busy very cool I'm honored thank you so
much another cool fan see here you go
zero - that's right everybody thank you
for not drawing me terribly I love this
this needs to be in love why it's rude
vulgar and offensive content policy
violation this violates the content
policy yeah
I'm gonna put that in the video I'm sure
nothing bad will happen thank you guys
so much for uploading these type of
memes how Oleg you identity subscribe if
you're nine years old everybody let's
take over the T series how many nine
year olds are there in the world there's
a lot of you that haven't subscribed yet
T series I await your response I know
you're scared but I'm not subscribe
everybody so we can take over T series
I'll see you guys next time
this is PewDiePie signing
[Music]
my fellow bros my fellow brethren my
fellow comrades the time has come for us
to fight